[Music]
if you've seen my recent facing fears
video you know I just came back from
Kissimmee Florida I also happen to have
a partnership with Kissimmee Florida so
while I was there vacationing enjoying
my time facing my fears I decided to do
one of my favorite things and do a
curbside consult Kissimmee edition I
literally ran around the streets of
Kissimmee Florida answering people's
questions here's what happened today
if bloods true color was blue and it's
only because oxygen is red that's a
great question so in your veins the
reason why you see the blue tip is
because the blood is slightly
deoxygenated so it has a blueish tip but
in reality blood is still red it's true
when we draw our textbooks and our
Anatomy pictures we always make it blue
but that's trickly for education
purposes which is the deoxygenated blood
which is the oxygenated blood but in
reality blood is still red so if you cut
your vein the blood is not gonna come
out I promise I've tested this many
times okay we got a question now yes
good for cold okay okay okay is it good
for a common cold I swear even ooh this
is Ashley
you think it's true Judy would and we
just went for before it's true
probably has something to do with the
electrolytes the salt making sure you're
getting your calories that it's warm it
stimulates blood flow to the area but it
works you have a medical question the
other medical question aspartame
okay what about aspartate okay so
artificial should not
truth be told from the research that we
have now harmful we don't yet know that
that it's harmful it's not existing yet
is it good for you
probably not number one aspartame is a
lot more sweet than regular sugar and it
conditions your brain to want more sugar
number two there exists bacteria in your
gut
that bacteria loves sugar and that's the
unhealthy bacteria that loves the sugar
you don't want those bacteria around
because they cause you to gain weight
they actually influence your cravings to
want more food and when you eat
aspartame you don't digest it so you
don't get the calories in the sugar but
the bacteria do so you increase the
number of the bacteria that crave sugar
so you're gonna want more sugar that
bacterias makes you more likely to eat
more food and get obese and all these
things if you want something sweet
occasionally maybe have a teaspoon of
honey something that brings some other
benefits have some apples have some
bananas you know things that in addition
to the sugar will have some fiber and
vitamins no I don't I want to get rid of
this belly that's okay we can bleep it
that's perfect I like that your passion
when I delete this but I don't have time
even to walk obviously I'm still gonna
tell you that you should make time to
exercise I guess what it doesn't have to
be a lot of time if you have 15 minutes
you can do something known as high
intensity training right for 30 seconds
you go as hard as you can and then for
two minutes you go slow and walk and if
you do that cycle for 15 minutes that's
really good exercising you to lose some
weight but let's forget about exercise
from home the real way to lose this is
actually by changing your diet there's
no one way that works for everybody a
couple of things that you can follow
that's gonna help cutting the amount of
calories you eat sodas
sweets pancakes white bread white rice
and even if you do like a half lowering
you don't have to stop eating them
completely you will see a big difference
oh I'm gorgeous
maybe you as a med student you have a
good medical question shoot tell me what
do you got the first thing the tip that
I'll give you is not to worry about the
test that's coming up three tests from
now right because you have a test this
week but then you also have a test the
next week the next and if you start
thinking about that whole line of
testing you're gonna go crazy and you
won't be able to focus on this test next
is to figure out how you learn best I
learned very well through listening not
so good from reading so what I would do
is I would replay my lectures over and
over again and listen to them next you
want to figure out what the best most
efficient way for you to learn through
like flashcards study cards and not just
by yourself
so it's about creating the cards and
then getting a partner or maybe a group
and doing it together maybe you're not
gonna remember the information if it's
written on the card but if you and your
partner talked about the concept you can
remember the conversation and then the
best technique that works in all
medicine you'll learn this you'll hear
it very often see one do one teach one
right so for you what does that mean
that means you see the information right
you study the information and then you
try and teach it to your friend big
answer right all right good stuff when I
was very good with my son okay I
had preeclampsia okay and I developed a
pulmonary edema okay now what is the
chances of that happening if I have a
second pregnancy because you you're now
fall into the category of someone who
has created preeclampsia in your first
pregnancy the odds are much more likely
that you'll have it that doesn't mean
that you will have it for sure but what
that means for you is when you go on
your follow-up visits with your doctors
when you start your next pregnancy you
have to make sure they all are aware
that you've had preeclampsia and that
they're very stringent in monitoring
your blood pressure symptoms of
preeclampsia as you know like headaches
swelling of the lower extremities high
blood pressure like all of these things
need to be really carefully monitored
because you can technically control it
very well or worst-case scenario you can
induce the pregnancy earlier on than
naturally would have but it will prevent
you from obviously having true eclampsia
which is obviously very serious but I'm
glad you had that question thank you so
much I love doing curbside consults I
think it's a great way to show that
doctors are relatable we're humans too
and most importantly it answers people's
medical questions and questions they may
be too afraid or embarrassed to ask
their own doctor now what makes this
even more exciting is that I can do a
curbside consult anywhere I've done in
New York City now I've done in Kissimmee
but if you have a recommendation of
where you think you might be cool that I
do it drop it down below in the comments
if you're enjoying the channel please
hit subscribe and as always stay happy
and healthy I think for everyone that
has
through hardship through medical
salutely thank you you keep us on the
track okay you can make it
I know it's hard it's gonna be hard till
we finish but it's a lawsuit thank you
for telling you them appreciate that
oh come on I can't I can't diagnose you
on the street like that I've seen this
okay let me see I mean I have seen it do
you mind just saying to the camera that
you're cool with this being on YouTube
you're cool TV is closed
[Music]